the platypus has been seen as a freak
and a fraud but now the animal reveals
rich new pathways in our evolution
nature reports the detailed results of
an analysis of the genome of Glenny a
single female Australian duck billed
platypus we're not very far from
Canberra just a few kilometres up the
road and this lake is perfect platypus
habitat they live in burrows deep in the
earth banks around here and they just
come out in the early morning in the
evening to feed the platypus is
beautifully adapted for its aquatic
habitat it's a lovely little creature
you can see that it is truly a mammal it
has fur and it feeds it's its young on
milk but it has a lot of reptilian
characteristics for instance this eye
structure is very much like a reptile
and particularly its reproductive organs
are like reptiles so much so that it
actually lays eggs Platypus is by itself
basically in its Genesis and species
there are no other things like the but
it was that's for sure it has one
relative called the echidna in Australia
which is also what we call a monotreme
which means that it only has one opening
on the rear end shall we say for
everything to exit and enter it has
features of mammals but it also has some
features of other animals the nature
paper that we've just published shows
the genome sequence and analysis of the
platypus people from America and the UK
and Australia were able to obtain a
sequence of platypus they were able to
break up its cells look at its genetic
code and then report that out us of
course a string of letters as we do with
genome sequences we were looking at the
whole set of Platypus protein coding
genes who comparing them to other genes
and other species from chicken to human
to Mouse and and the marsupial and we
were looking for differences and
similarities between the genes we were
looking to see what the Platypus has
that we don't have what we have that the
Platypus hasn't in Oxford curator of
zoological collection
Tom Kemp compares notes with geneticist
Chris Ponting so got as much use by
creationists just because it's some
nothing you can possibly evolve a thing
of the birds beak of mammals for
actually an egg but you know we know
better than that it's quite know
something about the fossil history it is
an extraordinary animal isn't it it's
this strange amalgam of different
features which are actually present in
the genome - it has all of these
different genes from birds and reptiles
as well as the other other mammals it is
an extraordinary creature that was in my
lectures I always call it the mystery of
the monotremes hmm and I could tell you
at least 6 different theories over the
last hundred years I serve what they are
we still don't with over 250 million
years ago the earth had a single
landmass Pangaea over time Pangaea split
into two smaller land masses the
ancestors of the Platypus arose on one
of these the supercontinent Gondwana
Gondwana then split into a number of
smaller continents including South
America and Australia the South American
monotremes died out so the modern-day
platypus is now only found on the
eastern coastal region of mainland
Australia and in parts of Tasmania
however bizarre alien they may seem the
monotremes are in fact the oldest
surviving branch of all mammals living
today when the first specimens came to
Europe from Australia they were the
thought have been a hoax a fraud indeed
there's a specimen the Natural History
Museum in London where someone has taken
scissors to it to prove that in fact it
was a fraud this specimen was regarded
with suspicion when it arrived at the
Museum and this was back in 1798 because
it had traveled here on ships that came
through what were known as the Indian
seas and the Chinese in particular were
well known for fabricating animals and
they made for example what was known as
an Eastern mermaid and this was made up
of part monkey and part fish so they
thought the specimen because a
fabricated creep
now what they did at the time was try
and remove the beak because they didn't
believe that the animal was real or not
surprisingly the genome like the animal
is a strange amalgam of reptiles and
mammals the genome is quite small like
birds and and reptiles but it has pretty
much the same suite of genes as humans
do there's about eighteen and a half
thousand genes and they're very similar
to two human genes but there are some
differences there are some genes that
don't exist in mammals were doing
chickens like egg yolk proteins for
instance so it's been terribly
interesting to explore the suite of
genes one of the major findings we
immediately saw is that has a phenomenal
range of receptors called vomeronasal
receptors that is the largest that we
have seen among any mammals what we
think that is is that when the platypus
dives underwater foraging for food it is
able to appreciate a whole different
types of chemical stimuli in its
environment and the odd thing about the
platypus is that it closes its eyes as
close as its nose while Syd dives and so
all of the chemicals that will be seen
by these receptors will enter through
the back of its mouth in such a way as
only previously been seen among
creatures like the hippopotamus another
aquatic mammal one of the extraordinary
things about the platypus is that it has
venomous Spurs the adult males are able
to envenomate they're able to inject
venom from the ends of their Spurs into
unsuspecting biologists or anyone else
and apparently it's excruciatingly ly
painful it's able to deliver a venom
which can kill dogs and that can
incapacitate humans for a number of
weeks it's so powerful and the genome
shows us that this venom looks like
reptiles although it has evolved
completely independently from reptiles
this is a wonderfully weird and strange
creature it is not that the God has a
fantastic sense of humor it's just that
we scientists cannot always second-guess
what we're going to find in nature well
for comparative genomics weird is good
we call it informative variation and we
can use the differences and the sin
molarity is sequence between the
platypus and a human to search for genes
and not just part of us genes but also
human genes and we can use it to search
even for the little sequences that turn
these genes on and off this genome
sequence is incredibly important because
it plugs a hole in our knowledge of
mammalian evolution we can use the
comparisons to say something about the
common ancestor that lived about a
hundred and eighty million years ago and
this gives us tremendous power to
explore the genome of all mammals I
think in the next ten years there'll be
an explosion of such sequences and so
beyond what we've been able to see for
the platypus we are able to now develop
the methods to tell in the genome how
species are similar to one another and
how they are different
you